there's a phenomenon I come out here and
some people hold up their Conan shirts
have you seen that right and they hold
them up to me like look look and it
looks to me like they're complaining
about the workmanship dragon it looks
this woman yeah you got one that guy and
they're holding them up and no that's
not a Conan shirt what the hell is that
what is that did you buy that
why how much did you buy that
stop showing it to people you're really
screwing up the Conan brand how much did
you pay for that did you buy it online
you bought it here we're connected with
this crime
how much did he pay for that you paid 20
bucks Jeff give me 20 but I give his
money back
put that away but I know it's so what is
it it's well put that away
why do you have a small candy bar with
you we give these out we gave this out
Ellen gives away television sets we give
away this look at the size of your bar
and it's probably left over from
Halloween yes it won't break here
wouldn't you wrap that and I can wrap
your blanket around the piece of shitty
candy we gave you my favorite my
favorite part of that towel is that when
he held it up I could see his face
through it it's a shitty and thin do we
have a stories I don't understand there
was a guy outside a truck who sold that
to you I don't think we're getting I
don't think that's guys connected to our
show Jeff we have to investigate this
people were selling highly flammable
Conan merchandise out of town
out of a taco truck that's not right you
know no one's gonna investigate no way
hey no I know I said you better look
into that Devils like I'll look right
into it yeah meanwhile he's on the phone
buying more Halloween
more Halloween candy fans telling him is
his telling his assistant remind me
Conan owes me 20 bucks yeah I'm getting
that 20 back from Conan I'll break his
legs and shake it out of them well
despite what you just saw the sad the
sad play that just played out stop
showing me the damn shirt I'm not paying
you back for that no and if you wear it
in the rain it's your own fault the
Conan logo just runs aha
[Applause]
the cops are gonna shut us down any